bonsoir monsieur lundi 12 octobre
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal ont
commencé suite avec les titres de votre
actualité locale
le gouvernement a annoncé 22 mesures
pour enrayer la hausse de la mortalité
mortalité routière des mesures
répressives
nous verrons ce qu'en pense jean yves
petit directeur du comité yvelinois de
la prévention routière de moins 13
octobre se déroule la journée nationale
de la sécurité routière et la ville
d'elancourt vient d'organiser son
premier forum de l'immobilier au
programme des conseils pour investir ou
plus simplement trouver une location
puis enfin le bilan du festival de bande
dessinée de buc c'était ce week-end les
amateurs étaient nombreux à la rencontre
des auteurs et l'hôpital privé de
trappes se met au rose l'association
admis a été cet après midi dans un
établissement pour sensibiliser au
dépistage du cancer du sein
toute la semaine dans le cadre du mois
d'octobre rose des événements sont
prévus chaque année en france sont 49
mille femmes qui apprennent qu'elles
sont touchées par cette maladie qui
reste la première cause de décès par
cancer chez les femmes
écoutez les précisions recueillies par
william l le dépistage organisé c'est
vraiment pour les 50-74 ans avec une
prise en charge totale de la
mammographie avec la palpation
après il ya certaines femmes qui vont
passer des examens plutôt bien souvent
parce qu'elle a des antécédents
familiaux tout en sachant que ces 5 %
des cancers
seulement donc finalement dire que qu'on
n'a pas besoin de faire une mammographie
parce qu'il n'a pas d'antécédents
familiaux
c'est pas une raison suffisante bien
souvent les femmes n'y vont pas parce
qu'elles craignent la douleur puisque
une mammographie ce n'est pas agréable
il ya une compression du sein mais c'est
de leur faire entendre que c'est une
douleur à très court terme pour pouvoir
éviter une douleur à long terme à savoir
un cancer qui serait détecté à un stade
trop avancé et sachez que vendredi 23
octobre à partir de 14 heures une
conférence débat est organisée à
l'hôpital de rambouillet sur le thème du
dépistage du cancer du sein
une initiative mise en place dans le
cadre du projet sud divine terre
d'égalité que nous avions reçues sur
notre plateau et dans le cadre de la
manifestation d'octobre rose bien sûr le
comité départemental de la ligue contre
le cancer ainsi que la nuit
l'association de dépistage de masse des
yvelines seront présentes et trouver un
logement une location ou devenir
propriétaire est souvent un parcours
semé d'embûches d'embûches entre les
agences les sites de location sur
internet
difficile de savoir par où commencer
pour faciliter les démarches de ses
habitants la ville d'elancourt a
organisé samedi le premier forum de
l'immobilier et de l'aménagement de
l'habitat des images signées mélanie
poker ils arpentent les allées à la
recherche de leur bonheur achat vente
location ou travaux pour y voir plus
clair c'est curieux se sont rendus au
premier forum de l'immobilier de
l'aménagement de l'habitat dans le
complexe sportif europe organisé par la
ville d'elancourt
c'est pas une mauvaise idée pour avoir
des contacts puis voir à peu près ce
qu'ils proposent déjà un premier temps
on va visiter
et puis comme honneur à la recherche
d'un appartement une maison donc
recevoir on va regarder le pas pour les
prêts 38 exposants ont répondu à l'appel
des agences immobilières des
fournisseurs des constructeurs
un moyen de rencontrer plus facilement
leurs clients potentiels dont la
démarche est facilité l'avantagé ici
c'est pour apprendre et contacte donc je
pense que nos clients bien sûr ils iront
voir prennent aux autres confrères bien
évidemment et
d'avoir sur un seul et même plateau les
acteurs locaux puisque essentiellement
monsieur de lagence de la vidéo en cours
et du mode france par ile de france
agence il encourt nous sommes
effectivement des acteurs locaux
une initiative mise en place par la
ville objectif répondre à une demande
des habitants et les encourager à
accéder à la propriété
on a décidé vu le nombre de demandes
qu'il y a de faire un salon avec tous
les acteurs compétents
en plus de nous on est bien sûr présent
mais on a donc les banques et donc moi
je sais pas négocier un taux pour bien
sûr no no no deal encore toi avant alors
là ils peuvent mettre en compétition les
taux il ils ont tous sur place
donc ça leur fait gagner du temps et
puis la qualité de vie puisque le but
c'est d'améliorer leur habitat plus de
400 personnes se sont rendues au forum
il pourrait être reconduit l'année
prochaine et même inspiré la communauté
d'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines pour un événement similaire
urbanisme à présent le programme
d'aménagement de la zac renard est déjà
bien avancé les 24 hectares d'anciens
terrain militaire situé au nord de saint
cyr l'école devrait accueillir des
logements mais aussi des commerces
favoriser la mixité sociale et renforcer
l'activité mais aussi désenclaver la
ville en les hiérarchisant les voies ce
sont les objectifs du projet dont la fin
des travaux est prévue en 2021
regardez ce reportage de william l
trente mille mètres carrés d'activités
économiques 1500 logements et 3000
mètres carrés de commerces voilà à quoi
ressemble le projet pharaonique de la
zac renard de saint-cyr-l'ecole répondre
à une demande de logement et redynamiser
le commerce le tout dans un quartier
paysager qui s'inscrit dans une démarche
intégrée de développement durable on a
fait un travail partenarial avec
l'architecte des bâtiments de france
pour pouvoir avoir un projet respectueux
de ce contexte patrimonial et puis avec
une implantation du végétal dans le
projet toute particulière puisque
l'architecte des bâtiments de france
nous a demandé d'avoir trois grandes
perspectives historiques qui sont
reprises dans le projet d'urbanisme et
sur lequel on aménage des promenades des
espaces de récupération des eaux
pluviales dans un principe aussi de
respect du développement durable ans
avec de nombreux promoteurs tels que
bouygues de la zone d'activités située
sur un ancien terrain militaire devrait
accueillir également une crèche une
école mais aussi un pôle sportif
une opération d'aménagement comme celle
ci elle a pour objectif de s'équilibrer
c'est à dire que l'aménageur il investi
90 millions d'euros pour acheter le
foncier donc le terrain mr la défense
pour réaliser tous les futurs espaces
publics l'aménageur réalise aussi les
équipements l'école la crèche le gymnase
et en contrepartie il vend les terrains
à des promoteurs immobiliers pour
équilibrer ses dépenses pour qu'il
réalise des programmes comme ça que vous
visitez aujourd'hui ce projet est aussi
l'opportunité de réunir deux quartiers
existants celui de la fontaine saint
martin à l'ouest et langevin à l'est
dont la seule fonction actuelle et
l'avenue du général charles de gaulle de
nouvelles voies participeront à cette
jonction la fin des travaux est prévue
elle pour 2021 et nous avons parlé
sécurité routière maintenant nous
recevons en plateau jean yves petit
directeur du comité des yvelines de la
prévention routière
merci et bonsoir bonsoir et merci d'être
venu sur ce plateau et d'avoir répondu à
notre appel
nous vous accueillons pour parler de la
journée nationale de la prévention
routière qui a lieu demain mais aussi
des chiffres de la mortalité routière
qui sont connus les chiffres du mois de
septembre
ils sont donc le nombre de morts
s'établit à 262 personnes soit une
baisse de 17 4% par rapport au mois de
septembre 2014
une baisse qui vient modérer une année
2015 marqué par la hausse globale des
victimes sur la route
oui absolument c'est les chiffres
nationaux évidemment car 200 et quelques
tué heureusement dans notre département
2015 est une
mauvaise année pour ce qui concerne la
sécurité routière comme l'était
malheureusement aussi 2014 les deux
années ont montré une hausse du nombre
de tués du nombre d'accidents du nombre
de blessés sur les routes de france pour
ce qui concerne le département les
yvelines où les chiffres sont évidemment
beaucoup plus petit nous n'avons pas une
hausse une hausse aussi sensible qu'au
niveau national
disons que nous sommes globalement au
même niveau que les années précédentes
donc le gouvernement a mis en place une
vingtaine de mesures actes il va
appliquer l'objectif c'est 2000
personnes tuées sur les routes en 2020
donc moins de 2000 personnes pour ça
qu'il ya différentes mesures donc et à
l'augmentation des contrôles notamment
des mesures concernant la protection des
usagers vulnérables c'est ce que vous
attendiez qu'est ce que vous en pensez
alors déjà les 2000 tués en 2020 c'est
pas notre gouvernement c'est une
directive européenne qui a divisé par
deux le nombre de tués d'ici 2020 ce qui
pour la france représente 2000 tu es
maintenant le donc le comité
interministériel de la sécurité routière
s'est réuni au mois de fin sur une île
vendredi dernier la c'est la première
fois du quinquennat certains estiment
qu'il était temps qu'ils se réunissent
compte tenu des mauvais chiffres de la
mortalité fin de la de la sécurité
routière en particulier mois de juillet
ou d'août alors
cette année il ya eu beaucoup de mesures
annoncées au 1er janvier il y en a eu 26
qui sont presque toutes mises en
application et là le gouvernement nous
annonce de nouveaux 22 mesures +33
mesures complémentaires ça commence à
faire beaucoup mais il était évident
qu'il fallait effectivement faire
quelque chose justement donc sur sur ces
mesures si vous vous en pensez ce que
c'est ce que vous attendiez car ça met
plus l'accent en fait sur le contrôle
vraiment que la prévention
oui oui c'est vrai mais il en faut aussi
du contrôle et la répression
le tout est que l'équilibré soit
maintenue entre la partie prévention qui
est fait par des associations telles que
la nôtre en particulier
et puis la partie répression et contrôle
qui est fait bien évidemment par les
forces de l'ordre et par la justice il
ya trois façons d'agir on peut agir à la
fois sur l'homme sur le véhicule et sur
la voirie c'est ça les trois facettes et
dans toutes les mesures que prend le
gouvernement
c'est à peu près équilibré et même si là
il y en a plus sur la partie humaine et
en particulier sur la partie répression
mais la plupart des mesures qui sont
préconisées qui seront pas toutes
nouvelles d'ailleurs où pourront pas
forcément tout du niveau du ministre
son vont dans le bon sens fait plus de
radars sur les routes c'est aussi
efficace que faire de la prévention
globalement oui il en faut
nous avons on parle justement de
plusieurs mesures chocs mesure un petit
peu phare alors cela ne n'a pas été
nommée elle devra pas être appliquée en
france en tout cas pas pour l'instant
c'est la tolérance zéro pour
l'alcoolémie et plusieurs pays européens
qui l'ont mis en place elle est souvent
mis sur le devant de la scène vous avons
demandé d'ailleurs avoue habitants et
saint quentinois ce que vous pensiez de
cette mesure ouvre en parler dans
quelques instants
regardez tant qu'à faire autant ne rien
boire et on s'aperçoit vite que quand on
boit un ou deux verres
enfin ça n'aperçoit pas mais en
définitive il reste l'accession altéré
donc définitif pourquoi pas la tolérance
zéro est plutôt fun tout à fait ça
changera pas grand chose à mon avis mais
bon personnellement j'ai partisans m
attends que peut-être victime se trouve
que c'est bien
on a l'habitude quand même deux de boire
à table ne serait ce qu'un petit peu de
vin ou de bière donc c'est difficile axa
appliquée certainement tolérance zéro on
peut même pu boire un petit verre de vin
c'est un petit peu dur coiffant une
titre une tolérance un peu plus un peu
plus forte
l'alcool c'est justement aussi un des
axes de lutte notamment chez les jeunes
c'est ce serait une bonne mesure ce à
l'alcoolémie tolérance zéro pour
l'alcool amy n'y avait pas beaucoup de
jeunes vous avez alors vous savez que
depuis le 1er juillet la tolérance pour
les jeunes enfin pour les permis
probatoires c'est 0,2 gramme d'alcool
par litre de sang ce qui correspond à un
verre de bière pour un garçon pour une
fille beaucoup moins
cette mesure était prise pour les jeunes
pour les inciter à mettre en oeuvre le
slogan connu depuis longtemps
boire ou conduire il faut choisir
maintenant comme l'a dit l'un de vous
une des personnes que vous avez
interrogé
ça va pas être facile à mettre en oeuvre
et j'aurais quand même signaler que
c'est pas parce qu'on change la norme
que ça va diminuer le nombre de tués sur
les routes puisque pour ce qui concerne
l'alcool la moyenne du taux d'alcool
relevé dans les accidents pour lesquels
l'alcool est impliqué c'est 1,6 g
d'éthanol par litre de sang
on est donc déjà largement au-dessus des
0 5 gramme autorisé aujourd'hui donc
c'est pas en abaissant à 0 que ça
changera quoi que ce soit puisque les
infractionnistes sont déjà largement en
moyenne au dessus de cette norme
ça c'est vraiment faim c'est un problème
qu'on veut notamment chez les jeunes
alors peut-être pas forcément les jeunes
conducteurs des gens qui ont leur permis
depuis plusieurs années qu'ils sont plus
considérés comme jane poynter mais qui
sont en dessous de la trentaine vers 25
ans il y aussi d'autres problèmes fait
qu'il faut peut-être combat et je passe
notamment je pense notamment à
l'utilisation des portables c'est aussi
un vrai fléau pour les jeunes au volant
ah oui même les moins chers on considère
que le
les accidents enfin que les téléphones
portables et autres smartphones sont
impliqués dans un accident de la route
sur dix c'est d'ailleurs l'objet d'une
des mesures qui ont été mises en oeuvre
au 1er juillet par le par l'état
d'interdire le port des oreillettes en
conduite nu c'était aussi un fléau
important oui et dans ce cas alors il
faut peut-être parce que vous prenez un
petit peu le relais du gouvernement sur
cette action là sur ce genre d'action
pour au niveau la prévention oui il faut
faire des je sais pas peut-être plus de
campagnes de publicité quels sont les
axes auxquels il faut vraiment
travailler pour ce qui concerne le
téléphone ou en ce qui concerne
globalement ça donne d'alcool eh bien il
ya de tout il ya des des campagnes
publicitaires mise en oeuvre par l'état
nous on n'a pas les moyens de faire ça
mais les campagnes publicitaires qui
sont qui sont très bien faites sur les
dangers enfin sur les conduites à
risques
il y a de la réglementation c'est ce que
fait l'état actuellement avec ces
nouvelles mesures qui vont être mises en
oeuvre
quand elles seront soit décidée soit
voté si ça dépend de la loi et il ya de
la prévention comme je disais tout à
l'heure la prévention qui est fait par
des associations telles que la nôtre
mais aussi par de l'éducation routière
dans les écoles
enfin en milieux scolaires écoles
collèges lycées et au niveau du permis
de conduire lui-même
donc il ya beaucoup de deux volets sur
lesquels nous pouvons agir sur lesquels
nous associations nous agissons et sur
lesquelles me semble-t-il l'état agit
aussi c'est peut-être aussi à l'école au
lycée de prendre un peu le relais
justement il ya peut-être plus
alors c'est pas un relais c'est que
depuis les années 50 l'éducation
routière est une mission de l'éducation
nationale nous sommes là nous les
associations et les forces de l'ordre
aussi d'ailleurs dans pas mal d'endroits
pour appuyer l'éducation nationale et
les enseignants pour réaliser cette cet
enseignement mais c'est bien une mission
l'éducation nationale depuis les années
50 voiliers ça date pas d'aujourd'hui
on parlait de salaires voilà donc
justement des campagnes de publicité il
ya de grands noms du cinéma qui se
propose justement d'aider et de proposer
lors leur action était réellement c'est
luc besson qui a fait une publicité de
prévention en lien avec l'alerté lancée
par la fédération internationale de
l'automobile
le mercredi 7 octobre cac 1,8 milliard
d'enfants se rendent chaque jour à
l'école de l'eau mon départ mieux ils
sont plus de 500 a trouvé la mort sur la
route alors que ce soit en france et
justement à l'étranger d'ailleurs on
voit sur la vidéo qui est en train de
passer sont des enfants un peu de tous
les pays que ce soit en afrique ou
peut-être en europe qu'est ce que vous
en pensez ce que c'est un prince qui est
suffisamment abordé
au moins en europe occidentale au moins
chez nous oui oui le problème vient
d'aborder je vois des petits des petits
noir laqué d'aider des séquences qui ont
été filmés en l'afrique visiblement
à force et peut-être c'était pas en
afrique une saison sans faute en
différents pays dans différents pays bon
peu importe il ya certainement les
endroits dans le monde où on peut faire
beaucoup plus pour ça que je pensais à
l'afrique mais des initiatives telles
que celles de luc besson sont à
souligner évidemment parce que ce sont
des gens qui ont une notoriété qui sont
reconnus connu apprécié et quand il
s'engage pour un pour un tel un tel
sujet je pense que ça marque les esprits
donc oui c'est bien une dernière
question pour finir cet entretien donc
demain c'est la journée nationale de la
sécurité routière
alors ces deux journées cela comme il y
en a plein est-ce que c'est peut-être
une façon d'appuyer vous allez faire
quelque chose en particulier pour faire
passer votre message
alors nous faisons tous les jours cette
semaine qui a commencé ça s'appelle
c'est aussi ce qu'on appelle la semaine
bleue c'est à dire la semaine pour les
personnes âgées
et c'est dans ce cadre là que nous
allons demain
à fontenay le fleury pour sensibiliser
les personnes âgées aux risques aux
risques qu'ils encourent sur la route et
toute la semaine nous allons nous nous
focalisons plus cette semaine sur les
personnes âgées
très bien merci jean yves petit d'avoir
répondu à nos questions et des venues
sur notre plateau au fond merci nous
changeons maintenant deux sujets si vous
êtes jeunes parents ou que vous attendez
un futur heureux événement cette
information va certainement vous
intéresser ce week-end se clôturait la
deuxième édition de la semaine du
massage pour bébé il existe en france
plus de 1600 instructeur pour cette
pratique qui militent pour cette
approche qui soulageait bien des maux
des tout petits à versailles pour cette
occasion un salon découverte était
organisée sur le thème du bien-être chez
tout petit avec différents ateliers à
destination des parents et enfants on
écoute marlene quéré infirmière
puéricultrice nous parler des bienfaits
de ces massages au micro de manip ok le
massage va stimuler tous les appareils
de l'organisme aussi bien l'appareil
digestif que l'appareil circulatoire et
respiratoire aussi les les appareils
système hormonal et immunitaires et puis
le dernier point ben c'est le calme la
détente des bébés qui pleurent un peu
moins c'est pas pour ça qu'ils font
leurs nuits mais c'est des bébés qui ont
qui passent mieux de des périodes de
réveil
et aux périodes de sommeil et si vous
êtes fans disent nous disent nos goûts 2
tom tom et nana il ne fallait pas rater
ce rendez-vous ce week-end se tenait la
22e édition du festival de bd de buc
sous les arcades du château de la ville
l'occasion pour les fans de rencontrer
leurs scénarii leurs scénaristes et
dessinateurs de bande dessinée préférée
sephora namani et mélanie poté pour sa
22e édition le festival de bd de buc
accueilli ce week-end dans le château de
la ville une cinquantaine d'auteurs
adultes et jeunesse français et
internationaux près de 6000 visiteurs
ont fait le déplacement certains même de
belgique
il y avait certes un auteur qu'on ne
voit rarement génome en belgique
et voilà principalement uniquement pour
ça en fait des auteurs comme comme que
les mulsanne qui vient d'australie donc
on le montrait rarement c'est pas
forcément la rencontre au niveau des
fictions qui m'intéresse c'est d'avoir
dessiné en fait ce qui me fascine
surtout c'est de le voir dessiner
peut-être parce que j'ai pas ce talent
et du coup je trouve ça toujours
extraordinaire se prêtait au jeu des
dédicaces de célèbres dessinateurs et
scénaristes comme nicolas tabary et rock
frank giroud bernadette després colline
wilson et bien d'autres un rendez vous
attendu par les bédéphiles comme les
artistes un créateur solitaire et
toujours en proie
pour l'autre au doute et le fait de
rencontrer des gens qui le suivent
depuis des années qui lui demander des
nouvelles de ses futures créations qui
les attendent c'est quelque chose de
rassurant
tom tom et nana ont permis un plein
d'enfants de démarrer dans la lecture
voilà parce qu'on on lit et on relit
voilà ils n'ont pas peur de relire et
alors donc il se forma forcément à la
lecture
ça me fait plaisir pourquoi on va devoir
vous lisez beaucoup comme tom et nana
oui expositions et animations venaient
agrémenter les séances de dédicaces ce
week end et les plus chanceux ont même
pu profiter d'un atelier d'initiation 9e
art qui fédère toujours plus d'adeptes
aujourd'hui plus d'un français sur trois
est amateur de bandes dessinées et comme
chaque lundi vous en avez l'habitude
maintenant nous retrouvons notre
chronique culturelle avec sephora neuf
années bonsoir c'est fois alors
aujourd'hui vous pouvez nous présenter
les différents ateliers artistiques
ouvert au public sur l'agglomération de
50 ans deviennent tout à fait qu'on soit
florennes alors je viens vous présenter
les ateliers qui permettront je l'espère
aux spectateurs de devenir des
spectateurs aguerris et nous commençons
tout de suite avec alors je précise par
contre juste avant que la liste des
ateliers est proposé n'est pas
exhaustive mais ç'aurait été trop loin
recensés donc nous commençons tout de
suite avec les ateliers théâtraux
proposé à la ferme de bel ébat de
guyancourt et son directeur qui nous
explique l'intérêt de ces ateliers c'est
un formidable exercice pour prendre
confiance en soi c'est un travail de
cohésion de groupe
c'est vrai qu'à une époque où il ya
beaucoup de pratiques individuelles
c'est un moment votre de collectif est
ce un moment fort où on échange des des
émotions où on est extrêmement solidaire
sur un plateau c'est très important
on joue pas nous c'est ce qu'on essaie
de faire de nos ateliers c'est que les
les gens jouent pas les uns à côté des
autres mais joue véritablement ensemble
ainsi pour vous rompre à l'art théâtral
trois ateliers sont proposés à la ferme
de bel ébat de guyancourt un atelier
pour les 10-18 ans autour du texte
pinocchio textes du célèbre metteur en
scène de joël pommerat les mercredis de
16h à 18h à partir du 4 novembre
également l'atelier pour adultes du
lundi soir de 20 heures à 22 heures
autour d'un texte de molière sous la
houlette de la compagnie viva compagnies
en résidence avec une représentation
prévue en fin de saison et enfin
toujours dans cet état d'esprit de
partage la ferme de bel ébat reconduit
son théâtre son atelier théâtre dévolu
aux demandeurs d'emplois pour retrouver
confiance et estime de soi à partir du
printemps
atelier sur deux semaines avec une
partie écriture et une partie en pro
vise à sion alors ce genre à date
lessard également à donner des clés de
compréhension du
on peut dire tout à fait ça permet de
sensibiliser le public au processus de
création du spectacle afin de devenir un
spectateur plus éclairés et c'est en ce
sens que le théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines a construit et
pensé ces ateliers la saison 2015-2016
du tas de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
scène nationale c'est évidemment une
série de spectacles mais également des
de nombreux moments à partager des
ateliers qui permettent à des publics
très diversifiés notamment à des publics
familiaux de découvrir des processus de
création et de s'initier à des langages
artistiques
l'idée c'est d'en faire des des
spectateurs avertis de leur donner
toutes les clés d'appréhension des
spectacles alors au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et proposer
toute une pléiade d'ateliers
intergénérationnel touzard tout public
aux côtés d'artistes professionnels
monte autour de leur spectacle de
création notamment tour de blanche-neige
et de l'opéra fidelio et pour la
première fois des ateliers d'écriture
sont également proposés aux côtés
d'emmanuel pireyre artiste en résidence
au théâtre de saint quentin et prix
médicis e 2012
deux projets également tous ensemble
qu'ils ont pour objectif de faire se
produire sur scène ensemble des amateurs
et des professionnels alors un projet de
chant choral est en projet de danse les
appels à candidatures ne devrait pas
tarder à s'ouvrir sur leur site
alors le prisme propose également des
ateliers de danse de musique et théâtre
conçue avec leur artiste associé avec
toujours ce souci de développement
artistique personnelle et du faire
ensemble qu'est ce que c'est également
et le faire ensemble c'est vraiment
toujours cherché à construire dans un
projet de deux collectifs pour que la
personne en fait puisse se développer
toujours accroître sa connaissance du
milieu du spectacle on écoute ses lignes
que saint qui nous on parle également le
prisme centre un centre de développement
artistique de saint quentin en yvelines
et les pratiques artistiques pour
destinée aux habitants sont au coeur
même de son projet
nous programmons bien entendu des
spectacles qui sont l'on va dire le
rapport à l'oeuvre à l'oeuvre d'art du
spectacle vivant
mais en ce qui concerne ces ateliers de
pratique artistique et ses oeuvres sont
toujours en appui de la pratique alors
quelques rendez vous importants pour le
prisme tous les samedis une fois par
mois les parents sont invités à venir
danser aux côtés de leur char nos
enfants en compagnie de claire génie
fois de boussoufa chorégraphe hip hop
animera également un week-end par mois à
partir de décembre et jusqu'à à mai un
atelier de danse avec une représentation
déjà prévue le 28 mai et enfin agatha
fofana est l'artiste associé proposera
pendant les vacances de février d'avril
un atelier danse pour les enfants à
partir de 6 ans côté musique un projet
va être remontée avec l'ensemble
amalgammes à partir du mois de novembre
qui associera les habitants au
conservatoire de musique de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines et enfin côté théâtre un
week-end prévu en janvier pour les
amateurs en présence de frédéric soulage
et un projet pendant les vacances de
février destiné aux enfants dirigée par
évelyne bas j'ai donc pour tout pour
devenir vraiment de bons acteurs à ce
qu'un atelier théâtre à oscar avait
également toujours leur traditionnel
traditionnels ateliers du lundi soir
pour les adultes à partir de 16 ans
dirigée par marie paule guillet
directrice artistique de la compagnie du
théâtre du sable chaque année en fait y
travaille on va dire sur le premier
trimestre ils sont plutôt dans
l'expérimentation avec des exercices des
jeux des choses comme ça et puis à
partir du mois de janvier ils
travaillent sur un texte généralement
sur une pièce plutôt du théâtre
contemporain et il ya une représentation
au mois de juin sur la scène du scarabée
et nouveautés un atelier d'improvisation
pour les 14-18 ans est proposé tous les
mercredis à la maison de quartier de
riez parc de 17h30 à 19h merci sephora
ce que vous même vous avez fait du
théâtre un petit peu un bip et c'est
vrai que ça sert c'est vrai que ça sert
ça donne confiance en soi ça ça aide à
mieux s'exprimer
donc n'hésitez pas à suivre les conseils
de sephora et renseignez vous pour un
atelier théâtre il ya vraiment eu
beaucoup de deux visites de d'ateliers
proposés vraiment c'est à ne pas rater
et vous en aviez aussi reparler déjà
assez fort à natacha atlas je rappelle
sera demain mardi 13 octobre en concert
à 20h30 au théâtre national de saint
quentin on
la chanteuse belge d'origine anglo
égyptienne présentera ainsi après cinq
ans d'absence son nouvel album myriade
rothko écrit produit et arrangé par le
tromper d'un trompettiste pardon ibrahim
maalouf on en parlera certainement dans
le numéro de kiosque de la mercredi
sephora tout à fait y aura tout un sujet
en fait qui lui sera dévolu on va la
rencontrer mardi et puis en exclusivité
vous aurez l'entretien qui sera fait
avec elle alors voilà kiosque c'est à ne
pas rater vous aurez peut-être quelques
images de ce précieux concert nous
verrons c'est bientôt la fin de cette
édition c'est même la fin tout de suite
vous restez avec nous pour regarder le 7
le sport de michael et demi d'euros on
revient sur le match de maurepas et on
revient sur les footballeuses également
de montigny le bretonneux
je vous souhaite une très bonne soirée
je donne rendez vous demain à 18 heures
pour une nouvelle édition du 7 8 le
journal
il
je